your new album dropped today I love
saying drop today and check out this
album cover that is your plane but
that's your car on the cover it is what
your Acura is that 1993 Acura 93 Acura
and that's your car I still drive it til
this day so it is a little crazy better
over two hundred and eighty-three
thousand mile 1000 miles have you you've
had to replace everything I did I did
have to replace everything but that's
how dear it is to meet us how much it
you basically fess up you took the shell
of that car and put it on that no I did
have to replace some things the interior
of course I redid that we have to paint
you know replace the engine but I loved
that car man it always reminds me of you
know the foundation that was laid and
where I started so you can never forget
where you came from no that's nice
[Applause]
people don't believe it but I still have
my 93 Ford Taurus do you think you have
a cool car oh yeah 93 Ford Taurus and I
want to get it fixed up someday and we
need to race someday and those two old
ads you know we should do that's gonna
be furious furious eight is gonna be
there you go you an accurate in a Ford
Taurus 60 miles an hour down a
straightaway
let's do that let's do that that'll be
very interesting you wanted to mention a
new video game that's very important is
that you you were just talking about f8
but this this video game there's one
based off of Furious 7 and it's called
Forza horizon 2 and for anybody that
wants to check it out you know it's on
Xbox
you know shout out to Microsoft but the
thing about it is they have an element
where you can donate to my foundation
which gives to underprivileged children
so nowadays video games are getting
pretty complex and that's a great thing
that's a great cause oh yeah that's good
that you did that Furious 7
I want to make sure everyone knows is in
theaters Friday all right you guys have
gotten the word out I'm curious I think
we have to yeah this morning and I had
an ad on my forehead for
then I went to the bathroom and Luda
versal was on my chest good that's
really good blue to Brussels is
available now and check your local Acura
dealer get yourself an accurate
you